surviving in somalia's betwa city has
turned into a dire challenge hundreds of
thousands of people have poured into the
city after severe droughts made their
remote villages unlivable
the influx is overwhelming the city but
displays families say it's better than
what they left behind
with nowhere else to go the United
Nations says displaced communities have
set up hundreds of scattered camps
themselves
horrible
Muhammad Adam is struggling to make ends
meet he's been searching for work all
day helping people move their belongings
he cares after his mother and younger
brothers but on a good day he says he
earns less than two dollars
I'm out here from early morning till
night this is the only work I've got I
wish I had better options
the Somali currency the Shilling is also
struggling
look at our currency it's worth nothing
this entire bundle of cash is just worth
about forty dollars
International Aid doesn't always reach
those who need it most
what we need right now is actually
ensuring that funding is going directly
towards local communities and making
sure that ingo's organizations like NRC
and also those at the Forefront are able
to directly support those who are
affected by it the desperation is
palpable
faced with the worst drought in 40 years
scenes of poverty and hunger are
becoming more common
Amina is among thousands who beg for
food hoping for sympathy
I have not eaten anything for two days
I've been begging for food but often
there's no response
it's yet another crisis for the
government which is already facing
political instability armed groups and a
weak economy roughly 70 percent of adult
somalis don't have jobs and for now
there is little hope things will improve
soon
Al Jazeera